المترجم: sara osman
المدقّق: Anwar Dafa-Alla
في أول يوم من عام 2011
أكملت ماريا عامها الرابع
في هذا اليوم، كان يسألني الكثير من الناس
لماذا لم تسجليها في المدرسة حتى الآن؟
و ما المدرسة التي ستدخلها
وما النظام التعليمي الذي سوف تختارينه لها
ولاحظت أن الموضوع يشغل الكثير من الناس
فهو قرار مهم في حياة الأهالي
فذهبت لصديقتي التي لديها الخبرة
في هذا الموضوع
وقلت لها قولي لي نصيحة
لكي أختار بها المدرسة
فقالت لي حسنا،
لا توجد مدرسة بها كل شيء
قومي بترتيب أولوياتك،
و أول مدرسة تعثري فيها
على أول ثلاثة مميزات
قومي بتسجيل ابنتك فيها على الفور
و لكنك تأخرتي،
وكلما أسرعتي كلما كان أفضل
أدخليها الصف الثاني
للروضة مباشرةً
فقلت لها حسنًا
فرُحت أُرتب أفكاري وقلت
فيم يفكر الناس عندما يختارون المدرسة؟
فوجدت أن الناس عادةً تفكر مثلًا
في الجانب الأكاديمى بالتأكيد،
يفكروا في الوسط الذى يشبههم،
وأيضا يفكروا في بعض اللوجستيات،
مثل مصاريف المدرسة، وأن تكون قريبة،
وأشياء من هذا القبيل
فقمت بفعل ذلك و اخترت مدرسة
و كانت مدرسة جيدة
و أمضينا ثلاثة سنوات تقريبًا في المدرسة
وبالطبع دَخَلت للصف الثاني للروضة مباشرةً
مثلما نصحتني صديقتي
وبعد ذلك، بدأت بعد ثلاثة سنوات
أُفكر في المعايير التي اخترت
على أساسها المدرسة
اللوجستيات كانت جيدة و مقبولة جدًا
كانت المدرسة بعيدة فذهبنا لنسكن بجوارها
و سكنا في نفس شارع المدرسة
لأن المدرسة شيء من المفترض أن
نرتبط به طوال حياتنا
و من ناحية الوسط فكانت جيدة أيضًا
ولكني لاحظت بعض الأشياء
أننا عندما نختار مدرسة،
وأعني بذلك مدرسة متميزة
فإن الخيار يأتي بجوانب متعددة،
وعلي أن أقبل بها جميعا
فكان من ضمن هذه الأمور؛ أنني لاحظت
في المدرسة التي اخترتها لماريا
أن الأولاد مدللين قليلًا
و هذا التدليل يظهر في أشياء مثل
درجة عنف أحيانًا تكون مقبولة
أو متاحة للأولاد
خاصة لو كانوا صبيانًا و نسمع كلام مثل:
هذا مزاح صبية و كأن هذا مقبول لو
أن الصبية هم الذين يمزحون
باليد أو بمزاح ثقيل قليلًا
و كان أيضا بتجاهل بعض الأشياء
و التي في رأيي لها علاقة بالتدليل
كان هناك تكلف قليلًا أو
تفاخر عند الأولاد
بين بعضهم البعض
من عنده ماذا و من فعل ماذا
فأصبحنا نفعل الأشياء لكي
نحكي عنها أكثر من أن نعيشها
فتلك الأشياء استوقفتني قليلًا
الجانب الأكاديمى كان جيداً جداً
لم أكن أتحدث مع ماريا قبل المدرسة
بأي كلمة باللغة الانجليزية
بعد ما دخلت المدرسة، وبدأت تتعلم
و هي حمدًا لله كانت مثل ما يقول الناس
"A Student" (تلميذة متفوقة)
مما يعني أنها تسير على خطى جيدة
ولكنّي لاحظت أنها عندما
تتكلم كلاما مهما
فإنها تستخدم اللغة الانجليزية
أي أنها تتكلم بالعربية بشكل طبيعي،
ولكن بمجرد أن تبدأ كلاما مهما
تتحول إلى اللغة الإنجليزية
فقلت لا؛ أنا أحتاج إلى
تقويتها في اللغة العربية
كانت وقتها في الصف الثاني الإبتدائي
فقلت سأطلع على منهج الصف الثالث
الإبتدائى لأقويها في اللغة العربية
اطلعت وقتها على كتاب اللغة العربية
للصف الثالث الإبتدائي
وكان الدرس الثاني يتحدث عن التلفزيون
و كيف أنه أحدث جهاز وصلت إليه البشريه
و أنه صندوق العجائب وما إلى ذلك
فقلت إذا الأمر ليس له علاقه
بالحروف و الكلمات
إنما بالافكار التي تدرسها باللغة العربية
والأخرى التي تدرسها بالانجليزىة
فمهما حدثتها عن أهمية اللغة العربية،
إذا كانت تدرس بالعربية
أن التلفزيون هو أهم شيء في الدنيا
وتتعلم بالانجليزية عن معاني
المواطنة والحقوق والحريات
فلن أستطيع فعل شيء حيال هذا الأمر
فبدأت مثل هذه الأمور تستوقفني
وحدث أمر آخر في السنة الثالثة
لإبنتي بالمدرسة
سافرنا وقتها إلى اوروبا
وعندما سافرنا إلى فرنسا،
ذهبت بها إلى مدينة ديزني
والحقيقة أن درجة الاثارة
التي كانت عليها ماريا هناك
لا تختلف كثيرا عما لو كنا
شاهدنا فيلما للكارتون بغرفتها
وقد أصابني هذا بالإحباط الشديد
وعندما رجعت،
أعدت التفكير في الأمر
على أي أساس اعتقدت بأن هذا
هو الأفضل للأطفال
او أن هذا ما أود تقديمه لإبنتي
أو هذا هو ما سيسعدها؟
فبدأت أتكلم مع الناس من حولي
كان هناك شخصين تعرفت عليهم في نفس التوقيت
أحدهم مصري مهتم جدا بالعملية التعليم
و تربية الاطفال
والآخر أمريكي مهتم
بماهية مهمة الإنسان في الحياة
هذان الشخصان الآن من أعز أصدقائي
فكنت أتحدث معهم، وبدأوا بسؤالي
أحدهم كان يهتم بماريا والآخر يسأل عني
فالمهتم بماريا كنت أسأله، ماذا أعلمها؟
فكان يقول لى، لأجل أن تصبح ماذا؟
وماهو أساسا دورك في حياتها؟
وكان صديقي الأمريكي
عندما أتحدث معه يقول لي
ما هو الشيء الذي لو فعلته
سوف تشعرين أن حياتك تشبهك؟
لو انتهت حياتي سوف أقول
أني عشت بالطريقة التي ترضيني
عندما أخذت أفكر طول الوقت
في كلام كل منهما
وكانا قد ظهرا في حياتي في نفس التوقيت
قلت لنفسي إن نظام التعليم
لا يقتصر فقط على الكتب التي سندرسها
الموضوع له علاقة بنمط الحياة
و القيم التي أحب أن أعيشها
وتراها ابنتي في أنا
وبالتالي سوف يكون لديها
هي أيضا قيمها الخاصة
ويمكن أن تعيش حياتها على طريقتها
فكانت اول مرة في حياتي أفهم أن
التربية و التعليم
بالفعل مرتبطين ببعضهم البعض
وأنها ليست مجرد كلمة
هي بالفعل الطريقة التي نختارها
لتعليم أولادنا
والوسط الذي يتعلمون فيه
وكلذلك معلميهم
وهذا جزء من تربيتنا لهم
بعدها مباشرة حدث أمر لابد أن أحكيه
بما أن ماريا تكلمت عنه
كنت أذهب إلى سانت كاترين كثيرا
ولكن بمفردي
لم أصطحب ماريا معي من قبل
وبعدها بدأت أفكر،
أنا أريد التواجد هنا بشكل أكبر،
أريد أن يصبح لي منزل هناك
كانت مواعيد عملي قد تقلصت،
وكان هذا شيء جيد
فقلت أني أريد أن أمضي
جزءا من وقتي هناك
فقلت أني لن أستطيع أن أفعل هذا،
لن أنقل جزءا من حياتنا إلى هناك،
بدون أن آخذ رأى ماريا
فاصطحبتها معي إلى كاترين ذات مرة
وكان ما يشغل بالي طوال الطريق
أن ماريا لم تكن سعيدة في مدينة ديزني
فكيف ستعجبها كاترين؟
فكاترين ليس بها الكثير أصلا
ما حدث هو أن ماريا بمجرد
أن وضعت قدماها على الأرض،
لم أستطع إيجادها
لعب وانطلاق وجرى وراء الحيوانات
و تقفز فوق الصخور
و أريد أن أتسلق هذا الجبل
وبالطبع جلست إلى البدو،
وكانت تتعلم منهم أشياء طوال الوقت
فلاحظت أن ماريا في خلال يومين فقط
كانت قد عرفت أشياء عن الأعشاب،
و أشياء أخرى عن الجبال
وكيف تجد الماء في الجبال
وكيف تعرف الإتجاهات من النجوم
و كيف تعد طعاما بدويا
و ماهو الفرق بين الجبل
والتل والهضبة والوادي
لقد تعلمت هذه الأشياء بالمعايشة
فقبل ذلك، عندما كان عندها مشروع بالمدرسة،
كانت تصنع فيه جبل وجزيرة
من صلصال وورق
كنت أشعر أن ابنتي أصبحت مهندسة
وهى ذاهبة إلى المدرسة بالماكيت
وكنت أشعر أن هذا أفضل شيء،
مثلما أن التلفزيون هو أفضل اختراع
وكنت سعيدة جدا
لكن عندما رأت هذه الأشياء على الطبيعة
فهمت ان الجبل و الجمل وكل هذه الأشياء
ليست مجرد سطرين في كتاب
ولا يمكن أن يكونوا ذلك
وعندما عدنا من كاترين قلت لها
ما رأيك يا ماريا لو تركتي المدرسة
وبدأتي تتعلمي بطريقة جديدة
فأخبرتني أنها موافقة
و لقد تعجبت من أنها وافقت بسرعة لأني
أعلم أن ماريا كانت مرتبطة بالمدرسة
فقالت لى أنا موافقة ولكن
فقط من باب التجربة
قلت لها حسنا،
قلنا لوالدها فوافق
ولكن فقط من باب التجربة
و سنرى النتائج
فانطلفنا
وأول ما فعلناه
هو أننا قمنا بإجراء بحث
بحث عن كل الناس التي تفكر فى هذا الأمر
اكتشفت أن هناك كنز من المبادرات و الكيانات
و مجموعات من الناس
تعلم أطفالها بطريقة مختلفة
و قد أحدث هذا فرق كبير
اكتشفت مجموعات كثيرة لأمهات يعلمون
أولادهم تعليما منزليا
أو تعليما لا مدرسيا
وطوال سنة كاملة لم نفعل شيئا
سوى أننا نتعرف على أناس جدد
ونسافر في رحلات ونسكتشف
فى هذه السنة قابلنا أشخاصا
مؤمنين جدا بما يفعلونه
فمثلا، قابلت ماريا
أشخاصا يتكلمون معها
عن الموسيقى العربية
وهم بالفعل يعزفونها ويحبونها
رأت العمارة العربية والخط العربي
عندما رأت هذه الأشياء
ممن هم شغوفين بها
أحدث هذا فرقا كبيرا
في إحساسها بثقافتها العربية
ذهبنا في كثير من الرحلات
داخل مصر وخارجها
ولكن
سفرنا هذه المرة كان مختلفا
إننا نسافر بالفعل من أجل نتعلم
أصبحت ماريا تتلقى كل شئ بهذا الشكل
فتعرفنا على كثير من الناس،
منهم مثلا رجل نوبي
كان يسير طوال الوقت وفي محفظته مقالة
تتحدث عن الشخصيات المتميزة
التي جاءت من جنوب مصر
لقد اهترأت المقالة
من كثرة ما كان يعرضها للناس
من اول سيدنا موسى
وحتى تاريخ كتابة المقال
تعلمت من البدو أشياء كثيرة
لها علاقة بطبيعة معيشتهم
وقصصهم من التراث
وكان هذا أمرا مهما
وفهمنا من خلاله أمورا
مثل أن حكمة الأجداد وكبار السن
هى أمر مهم في عملية التعليم
و قد استفدنا منها الكثير والحمد لله
فمثلا أصبحت تنظر لزيارتنا لجدتي
و زيارتها هي لجدتها بشكل مختلف
تجلس إليهم وتشعر أنها تتعلم منهم
فتبقى لنا الجانب الأكاديمي
فسجلنا بالفعل في مدرسة في أمريكا
هي مخصصة للمتعلمين منزليا
منهجهم ممتاز ولا تستغرق
الدراسة الأكاديمية أكثر من ساعتين يوميا
وهناك معلمون رائعون يساعدون ماريا فيه
ولدينا أيضا مجموعات تعمل
على بناء شخصية الطفل وتشكيل وجدانه
وهذه هي الأشياء التي أرى
أنها تشكل فرقا في هذا السن
والحمد لله رزقنا الله
بمعرفة أشخاص جيدين جدا
مضى الآن سنتين على تجربتنا
في التعليم اللامدرسي
واذا أردت أن أختار 3 أمور
أشاركها معكم
أول شئ هو أن ماريا أتت
إلى مكتبي يوما فقابلت مديرتي في العمل
ديانا صديقة مقربة لي،
فسألت ماريا بماذا تشعرين؟
فقالت لها أحس بالحرية
فقلت ربما لأنها لا تستيقظ في
وقت معين أو ترتدي زيا معينا
(ضحك)
(تصفيق)
فقلت ربما لأنها لا تستيقظ في
وقت معين أو ترتدي زيا معينا
فوجدت أن الأمر أكبر من ذلك
الفكرة هى أنها مثلا لو
أرادت أن تشتري حيوانا أليفا
فهى ليست مضطرة أن تشتري قطة أو كلبا
لماذا لا يكون جملا؟
أى فكرة الخروج من ضيق المتاح
إلى براح الممكن
هذا أمر مهم جدا
أن الإنسان لا يلزمه
دائما أن يفكر في المتاح
وإنما فيما يحتاجه
يمكنها أن تصنع شيئا مختلفا،
هذا ما كان يهمنا فعلا
الأمر الثاني والذي أحدث فرقا لكلينا؛
ولابد أن أقول (لكلينا)
لأني أشعر أني أتعلم معها
هي فكرة طلب العلم
لا أعلم منذ متى تحول العلم إلى أمر مفروض
يفرض في وقت معين
من الساعة كذا إلى الساعة كذا
يفرض في موسم معين
ندرس في الشتاء
و ننسى ما درسناه في الصيف
وندرس في مكان معين
فأصبح العلم أمرا يطلب
وبشكل مستمر
بداية من سؤال أسأله
أثناء حديثي إلى جدتي ووصولا
أنني أذهب إلى مؤسسة
تعليمية أتعلم شيئا بشكل منظم
ولكن هذا كله يأتي من إنسان يطلب العلم
ومنفتح على العلم
الأمر الثالث هو الإستكشاف
وهذا أمر مهم؛ لأننا
لم نكتشف في رحلتنا فقط الأشياء من حولنا
بل أن ماريا اكتشفت أيضا
ما المهم بالنسبة لها في طريقة التعلم
كيف تحب أن تتعلم
هي مثلا أكثر ما تحبه هو
المسرح و الرحلات الميدانية
ولكن أيضا اكتشفنا الناس
وكان هذا أمرا مهما
و اكتشفنا ردود افعالنا
تجاه ردود افعال الناس
فمثلا كنا في أحد التجمعات
وسمع أحدهم أن ماريا تتعلم تعليما لامدرسيا
وكان شخصا تلقى تعليمه خارج مصر
و كان حاصلا على أعلى الشهادات
فعندما عرف أن ماريا تتلقى تعليما لامدرسيا،
انصرف ولم يكمل الجلسة
لقد كان معترضا بشدة
على ما نفعله في حياتنا نحن
من ناحية أخرى، مثلا أم أحد الأصدقاء
هي تعيش في محافظة أخرى غير القاهرة
ذات مرة جاءت إلى القاهرة وتعرفت علي
فلما تقابلنا صباحا قالت لي
أنت بالطبع لم تستطيعي احضار ابنتك
لأنها في المدرسة الآن
فقلت لها لا ابنتي لا تذهب إلى المدرسة
فقالت لى اذا أين هي الآن؟
فقلت لها هي في محل عطارة
فقالت لى هل ستتركيها في
المحل حتى ننتهي؟
فقلت لها لا هي تعمل هناك
وقبل أن أكمل قالت لي
(تصفيق)
قبل أن أكمل حتى قالت لي
هل أخرجت ابنتك من المدرسة
من أجل أن تعمل في محل عطارة؟
وبعدها قالت لي، حسنا يا ابنتي،
وفقكم الله
فشعرت أنها بالفعل تحترم قرارنا
فالفكرة هنا هو الحكم على الناس بالتعميم
والصور النمطية
أن هذا سيتقبل الأمر وذاك لن يتقبله
ولكن أهم اكتشاف
في كل تلك الرحلات
أو الشيء
الذي أدعو أن تتعلمه ابنتي
ونتعلمه جميعا
هو اكتشاف الإنسان لذاته واحتياجاته
لو لم تستفد من كل تلك التجارب
سوى أنها في وسط زحام الحياة
يمكنها أن تستمع إلى صوت قلبها
وتفعل الشيء الذي تشعر بأنه مسئوليتها
وأن هذا ما يرضي ضميرها
اذا وصلت إلى هذا الإكتشاف
فسوف أكون أسعد إنسانة في العالم
(تصفيق)
ولكن الشيء الوحيد الذي أود قوله
أنه عندما أخبروني
عن فكرة المحاضرة هنا في TED
قلت لماريا وكانت
النصيحة الوحيدة التي أخبرتني بها
لا تحدثي الناس وكأنك تشجعينهم
على ترك المدرسة وعمل شيء آخر
فقط أخبريهم بأن هذا الإختيار متاح
وأن أى شيء متاح
(تصفيق)
أشكركم بشدة